you could recognize the steeple of
saint-hilaire from afar, inscribing
an unforgettable figure on the horizon where
cambrai had not yet appeared when
from the train which, during easter week, would
bring us from paris my father saw it
spinning in turn, especially the  furrows
of the sky making his little rooster run in all directions
he told us then
we took the blankets we are
aribert and in one of the longest
walks we did in combret
there was a place where the road
suddenly narrowed with butchers  sure an
immense plateau closed on the horizon by
jagged forests that only exceed
the fine point of the bell tower of
saint-hilaire
but so thin so pink that it
only seemed scratched against the sky by a fingernail
which would have liked to give this landscape
to  this table just of nature this
small mark late it is unique
human indications when you get
closer and you can see the
rest of the square tower and gave
trout which - rod subsi  ster next to
him one was struck especially from the
red to very dark bridge of the stones and
parent reached monotonous it seemed
rising above the stormy vinyl
of the vineyards a ruin for
almost color
the Virginia creeper often in the square
like great  price one my grandmother
made me stop to look at it from the
windows of her tower placed two by two
the ures above the others
with this just and original proportion
in the distances which does not give
beauty and dignity only to the
human face  he let loose at
regular intervals shutters of
crows which for a moment whirled around
, shouting as if the old stones which
they had left to cavort were
sponsored to see become suddenly
uninhabitable and giving off a principle
of infinite agitation the  had struck and
repelled then after having re-emerged and in all
directions
the violet velvet of the evening air
suddenly
calm  these few posed here
and there do not seem to move but
perhaps pump a few insects on the
tip of a pinnacle like a seagull
stopped with neither mobility of a fisherman at
the top of the pad without really knowing
why
my grandmother found  at the steeple of
saint-hilaire that absence of
vulgarity, pretentiousness and pettiness which
made it m hurdles and how rich with a
beneficent influence nature was when
the hand of man had not had
its base and the gardener of madron of
tents shrunk  and the works of
genius and no doubt any part of
the church that could be seen distinguished it
from all other buildings by a kind
of thought which was a gun to it but
it was in its steeple
it seemed to become aware
of itself  affirmed an
individual and responsible existence
it was he who spoke for her I
believe above all confusedly of a great man
even found in the bell tower of the congress what
for her was the most valuable in the world
the natural air and the  air distinguish we
don't know about architecture 1.10 and my
children
you who tell me if you want
he may not be handsome in the
rules but you know weird figure
pleases me I'm sure if he played the
piano he wouldn't play  no circle and
looking at it with her eyes following the gentle
tension the inclination to sell her
sales of beer which was approaching
rising like mad magi who premium
she was neither knows so well at the outpouring of
the arrow that her  sounded record
launched with her and at the same time she
forgot herself friendly in old
worn stones whose setting only
illuminated the fact is qu
yves from the moment she entered
seven sunny zones softened by the
prince light  and all of a sudden mounted well
plotted - trails like a song taken over in
a head voice a notable above it was the steeple
of saint-hilaire which from year to year to
all occupations at all hours from
all points of view  of the city
their figures  the body does not lie their
consecration from my room could only
see its base which had been
covered with slate
but when on Sunday I saw them on
a hot summer morning with a torch and
a black sun
I said to myself I remain there  you have to get
ready to go to la grosne and if I
want to have time to go kiss 30
tell you and I knew exactly what
color the sun had on the square
the heat and dust of the market
the shadow cast by the blind on the  store
where Mum might enter before
a mask smelling of unbleached canvas
to buy some handkerchiefs
that you will give her, arching her waist, pointed to
the boss who, while preparing to
close, had
come from years in the back of the shop
past savès  of Sunday and
soaping his hands as he used to
every five minutes
even in the most
melancholy circumstances of rubbing against
each other the
corporate slab of fine games
and success when afterwards  the mass we
entered to say to say gold according to them
to bring a brioche bigger
than usual because our cousins had taken
advantage of the good weather agreed in tiber
to have lunch with us we had good
ither the bell tower which d  'auray and leather
itself like a larger bun
bing with scales of dripping
fiq sun bomer and its sharp point
in the blue sky and in the evening when I come
back from a walk and think about
when it would take everything to say
good evening to them my  mother and no longer see her
he was on the contrary so dom or in the
ending day who venerate her
to be put down and buried for a year a
velvet cushion on his arm on the sky panis which
had yielded under his pressure had
hollowed itself out slightly for him  make its
way and flowed back over these bumps and the
cries of the birds that circled around
it seemed to increase its silence and
still launch its arrow and give
it something
fable even in the races we had
to do behind we are there o  where you're
not laughing everything seemed orderly
compared to the bell tower popping up here and there
between the houses
perhaps even more moving when it
appears that's how it is without a church is
certainly there are many others that are
more beautiful seen  in this way and I have in
my memory of the bell tower vignettes
of passers-by from the roofs which have a different
character of art than that which compose
the sad streets of cambrai I
will never forget in a curious
town in normandy close to baalbeck
from  charming 18th century hotel which
seems to me in many respects dear and
venerable and between which when
you look at it had a beautiful garden which descends
from the parents towards the river the spire
gauthier jean church which hides sitting
and seems to have finished overcoming their
facade but of a material so different
so precious so canceled so rossi varnish
that we can clearly see that it is no
more a part of it than of two large plain pebbles
between which it is caught on the
beach the arrow for  pure was born there
take the help of a few shells
were to surround them she is there cdma
even in paris in one of the districts the
drums the east of the city I know a
window where you can see after a first a
second and even a third plan  makes
you a mons the of several streets a
purple bell sometimes reddish sometimes also
in the noblest test big shooting
the atmosphere of a black of accounts and
ashes which is none other than the tome
of saint-augustin and which gives  to this
city of paris the character of some
seen from rome by piranesi but as in
one of those little engravings with a few
loops my memory and no longer run them
she could not put what i had
long lost the feeling that
makes us not not  to consider a thing as
a spectacle but to believe in it when a being
without equivalent none of them holds
under its dependence a whole deep part
of my life as does the memory
of these aspects of the bell tower of congress
in the  streets that are behind the peas
that we come back to five o'clock when we were
going to pick up the beings at the post office at a
few nursing homes on the left
suddenly raising a sim to isolate
the ridge line of the canvases that if on the
contrary we wanted to enter ask for
news from madame ca zerah
followed with their eyes this line that had become a pass after
the descent of its other side
knowing that it would be necessary to turn at the
second Russian after the bell tower let's
push further if we were going to
the station we saw it obliquely let's show
of profiles of edges and surfaces
new ranges a solid surprised an
unknown moment of its revolution or that
of the edges of life theft the amci of
muscular picked up is reassembled by
the perspective seems to have sprung in from
the effort raises the chief zay  to launch
his arrow in the heart of the sky it was
always to him that it was always necessary to return
always to him who dominates and where only
the houses of an unexpected end raised in
front of noah like the finger of  god in
the body usefulness hidden in the crowd of
humans without me confusing him 10 for
that with her
and even today if in a large
provincial town or in a district of
paris that I know a passerby who
put me in  my path shows us in the distance
like a point of reference such a belfry
the
hospital do they have steeples of the wind the
tip of his ecclesiastical bonnet at the
corner of a street that I see taking so
that little my memory can obscurely
find me some  lines of resemblance
to the figure of the sheikh and the
passer-by disappeared if he turns around to make sure
that I do not lose my way a little at sony rate
not noticing it who, oblivious to the
walk undertaken or the race
obliged, remains there in front of the  steeple
for hours
immobile try to remember
feel deep inside me lands conquered
from oblivion which dry up and rename themselves
and no doubt then and more anxious
mans than earlier when
I asked him for information
I'm still looking for my way I'm turning
a street but it's so